and is with us in Florence South
Carolina hi and welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
good afternoon day I'm so excited to
talk to you you can't imagine well I'm
honored thanks how can I help so excited
um my husband and I are in pretty good
shape financially and we are also
Corvette people cool yeah and we are
fortunate enough to have a 1980
collector car 93 call show quality zr1
Wow
and then we have two daily drivers and
they're both old ones a 98 Grand Prix
that I drive and the other one is a
grand cheap a Grand Cherokee pink that
my husband Jason all paid for long ago
we have an opportunity to buy another
car like a collectible or to drive well
um to drive it was it would be a daily
driver for me
the Corvette Convertible it's a color
combination I've wanted for a long time
how much is how excuse me how much is it
$35,000 what is it it's a Corvette
Convertible yeah what's your not 2009
okay so that's uh that's about okay yeah
and what's your household income
household income is about five thousand
a month from my husband side and another
nineteen hundred from my side but we do
keep them we don't keep them separate as
in his and hers money we keep we keep
the larger amount for our checking
account we keep the smaller amounts yeah
but your household income is 6024 so
it's eighty five ninety thousand bucks
right okay and what does he draw and you
got you already told me those okay yeah
now your two collectibles are
collectibles that I don't count those
much yeah I'm doing investments yes we
do we have about six hundred six
thousand dollars in investments okay and
you're going to pay cash for the daily
driver $35,000 vent um I don't want to I
wouldn't buy it if you didn't pay cash
for it well it scares my reasoning our
investments are making better money then
then why don't you borrow on all the
collectibles and go put that money in
investments borrow collectibles
I don't the same logic which is flawed
by the way well what I wanted to do was
take a 2.7 percent
home equity loan on my fully paid for a
house that's that's ludicrous
okay I would not put my home at risk for
a car
well the home's paid off to it I
wouldn't put my home at risk for a car
okay I don't pay the bill they take your
home yeah but yeah yeah but what mmm you
got six hundred thousand bucks pay cash
for the stupid car or don't buy it it's
your grandmother would whip you for this
discussion she paid cash
you really nodded you pay off your house
if you give you believed in borrowing
money I yeah I don't like borrowing
money um you just gotten in on twit
about this car is what it is in your
brains not working because this is
called I try to make my brain work
because but I'm so frugal and so careful
yeah and yet you found this car you got
car fever yeah cuz it's the color combo
it's convertible its car y'all have
talked about for years
you found a sweet car I did yeah I did
listen you've done a great job with your
money your millionaires you can afford a
thirty five thousand dollars buy the car
yeah they touched for it yeah let me
guys to sell something have to cell
phone well so what do it just a little
bit of money little bit of moral
investments so it's not much money at
all alright so in your opinion that's
not out of the realm of know what that
car is reasonable financing it is
unreasonable okay okay yeah you're a
millionaire yeah I know you make ninety
thousand bucks a year yeah you've done a
great job
you know Corvettes so actually you're
probably getting a great deal on this
car I would guess I don't know it's got
twenty twenty-five thousand miles on it
a little owner wave a little cash unders
no tell me what deal yeah I think we
would - alright so I'm not I'm not
I shouldn't be stressing over this
shouldn't be stressing over buying it to
the point that you go borrow money on
your house to buy it yeah yeah I'll just
buy the car okay that makes sense you've
earned it I think I appreciate that
thanks for the call one other thing I
have to tell you okay because of you a
grown nice in our family has finally
finally come to her senses and is good
on um deaths noble cool yeah yeah I've
worried about her for years and she's
finally come around well I'm glad by the
way I've got a 79 model l82 in my garage
for speed go for speed cool sweet very
cool hey thanks for the call you're
welcome bye bye this is the Dave Ramsey
show open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five something
bout Corvettes I'm sorry these new ones
oh those new ones are there have you
seen the new ones oh they're just
ridiculous
mmm hi you know everybody's got their
deal Mastercraft boats this is why you
work you work so you can give and so you
can live and you how to do more giving
than living by the way and keep these
things in balance but I want you I want
I want you to learn to enjoy your money
that's part of why you work and that's
and you shouldn't be ashamed of it like
Lisa on Facebook how do you justify
building wealth when there's so much
need in the world the lady has done
nothing wrong Lisa she's that they've
saved money they've lived on less than
they make that they're exceptional
people they've done a great job there
wasn't anything selfish about what she
was talking about nothing out of line
about what she was talking about except
for the borrowing money part but you
know yeah she we need to get back to
celebrating when people win not
celebrating greed and not celebrating
conspicuous consumption as a percentage
of your income meaning if you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year you
don't need to be driving a hundred
thousand dollar a car that's stupid that
that's ridiculous
but this idea that somebody has done
good and one in the market that they did
a good job they should that you should
you should celebrate them enjoying that
this jealousy and envy stuff that some
of you from your supposed spirituality
have gotten into you're pitiful you're
pitiful not the lady that called that's
not one of them that's not directed at
her but it's more in defense of her that
she has you know I wanted I wanted to
buy that Corvette they had six hundred
thousand bucks they had paid for house
in addition of the 600,000 bucks saved
up they worked their whole lives for
this
this is something this is an item that
is a special item to them it's not an
impulse it's not a to use a bad metaphor
in this case upon a drive-by you know
it's not an impulsive decision and so
you know yeah you know maybe you've
always wanted to go on a cruise maybe
you've always wanted to have a Harley
maybe you've always wanted to fill in
the blank and when it's a very small
percentage of your world and you're a
big saver and a big giver in addition to
that then you should buy that item and
you should enjoy it and we should
celebrate with you your success because
in this culture we should celebrate
success and not look down on it as if
someone did something wrong
but the politics of envy the spiritual
disease of jealousy has been used in
this culture to divide instead of to
celebrate and it's got to stop you guys
it's got to stop so I'm all about that
lady having her car that she's looked
for for a long time I think that's
awesome
I think that's great again it's a small
percentage of her world three and a half
percent of her net worth is in her car
and so if you have a net worth of a
hundred thousand dollars that puts you
in a three thousand five hundred dollar
car that's the same ratios we were
discussing with her you following this
if you have a net worth of a half a
million dollars that you're driving a
seven thousand dollar car is just I mean
you know I'm sorry it's you driving a a
seventeen thousand dollar car it's the
same ratios very reasonable you couldn't
call that person greedy or self-absorbed
or any of those things you would just
say they're one and I'm smiling with
them as they celebrate winning and you
know here's an idea once you lift each
other up instead of spending all your
time telling everybody what they're
doing wrong spend all your time saying I
mean I horse correct people don't get me
wrong but I mean this idea that that
somehow someone has is morally superior
or because they think you should give
all your money away that you earned that
doesn't make you morally superior it
just makes you small-minded it makes you
someone who doesn't celebrate success
that's all it does so you know hey cheer
you know when somebody catches a pass
and scores a touchdown that's an okay
thing guys this is the Dave Ramsey show